no one knows about you you're the first
person i've told that to
[Music]
did you miss me i know i've missed you
this new gossip girl really is your baby
when did you first have this idea for
the revival and how did you pitch it
well josh's stephanie came to me because
a couple they'd tried a couple different
ways and they couldn't really crack it
and they finally were like you know what
let's talk to josh saffron and if he
wants to do it let's do it and if he
doesn't let's not
and they came to me and they were like
only if you have an idea that you love
and i was like i don't
so i walked away and by the time i had
gotten into my car i called stephanie i
was like actually i have an idea
and then it just stuck with me and i
couldn't let go of it i was so thrilled
to discover that the audience finds out
who gossip girl is i'm calling it gossip
group
in the very first episode how long has
that been the plan
from the beginning from the first time
saffron pitched us his take on the show
that was always that was always part of
the pitch which we loved because it was
an inversion of the original
i wanted to focus on the teachers and i
wanted to see what would happen if the
teachers
sort of tried to regain control of these
sort of like kids that were out of
control
and knowing that they were gossiping
from the top and watching it destroy
them
what are the pros and cons to having
multiple people act as gossip girl in
this show
it allows for actual convert like dan
alone would have been boring to watch
him for 121 episodes just sit there
typing
they actually get to talk and they get
to debate whether this is a good idea or
a bad idea some tips they get
in future episodes they really have to
some of them disagree and there's like
battles over it so i think that adds
like a whole new layer
if i wasn't born into this world
maybe i could write myself into it
the audience had a very strong reaction
in the first series to dan
being gossip girl did that impact or
shake things up when you approach this
new series well in a
good way dan being gossip girl actually
laid the foundation
for the way that the new show builds off
the old show because it's very much part
of the mythology
of gossip girl in the show that gets
excavated
and kind of repurposed in the present i
really think
uh for the audience the first time
around didn't get to see dan sitting at
the kitchen table with jenny next to him
and he was posting something about her
and he had to watch it happen to her
when she read it right in front of him
i felt like this time around we wanted
to see that i want to make the audience
complicit in gossip girl
being along with dan basically as you
see
what it told it takes on you to report
on the people you love the most dearly
so
it's just a different approach to the
storytelling you know it was a it was a
mystery
in the first season at the first show
and uh and this show is just a different
approach and so the audience can
focus on other things i guess and see
the see the toll
that being gossip girl can take on
people gossip girl
an anonymous instagram account that
spies on our students
we talked about nate archibald and the
pilot dan humphrey is now a writer
what other teases can you give me about
our crossovers in this first season
there are a whole bunch of recurring
characters who appear in episode 10. no
one knows that but you you're the first
person i've told that to
and it's a whole bunch it's not just one
and i'll just leave it at that
constance billard alumni not gonna say i
can't say i just think
honestly being in the same world again
and hearing where the characters went
and where they are now
and knowing that they exist in the world
and hearing these little tiny mentions
of them throughout i really love that i
think it's really great for the fans but
also just keeps the
show the original show alive while
letting the new show stand apart
what is one character that you would
love to bring back darota
i mean we always knew it was one of us
right i always thought it was soroda
you